طيب دوحه اعلنتي عن دخلك الشهري على تيك
توك واثار هذا الاعلان جدا الكبير كيف
راقبتها الجدل يا ضحى
والله الجدل كان في صالحي ما كانش مضر الي
فالحمد لله يا ربي ما شفتش حتى مضره وفي
ناس يعني هي اغلبيه الضجه صارت فهمت الناس
الموضوع غلط ولسه الناس فاهمين الموضوع
غلط طب انت فهميهم يا ضحى موجوده معنا على
الهواء مباشره فهمينا
طيب الموضوع انه في ناس مفكرين انه انا كل
ساعه بدخل المبلغ هذاك وهي صارت معي صدفه
مره في الحياه يعني مره في حياتي دخلت
المبلغ هذاك فالناس هم مفكرين طب وانا كل
ساعه بدخل المبلغ مبلغ
20 مليون دينار تونسي يعني 6500 دولار
امريكي
في الساعه يعني اقل اقل اقل اقل خمسه ولا
اربعه في الساعه بساعه واحده مش بالساعه
يعني كانه كل ساعه انا بتدخل المبلغ هذاك
لانه في مرات بضل يعني بتعب اسبوعي بفتح
كل يوم وما بدخل ولا قرش يعني انا ليش
الناس بتشوف كانه الساعه هذيك اللي انا
دخلت فيها انا في مرات شهر كامل بفتح وما
بدخل ولا قرش